foreign
James Harden and Marcus Smart kick off
the NBA season with a flop shimmy and a
brick on opening night
come on
oh give it to him you gotta make that if
you're going oh yeah
the Champions Club
I can't get a number two Patrick Beverly
really who who can forget this
as a freelance photographer hey man
listen
oh that's when he got attacked usually
that's when they were like get him out
of here
he's going to use the camcorder you got
to toss him for that too
hey
can you get HR on the phone I'm getting
bullied at work and number one Chuck
Chuck we checked the tapes again and
found more incriminating evidence
no I love this you can't hit somebody
run balance
backwards
oh Draymond Chuck green
[Music]
You've Won it twice this year it was
awesome man for the same thing that's
okay